- One of your first acting jobs
is actually dubbing cartoons?
- Not dubbing cartoons, but
dubbing foreign film.
I mean, when I was growing up on TV,
they would have these
kind of gladiator films
or Speed Racer cartoons.
- Yeah.
- Right, Speed Racer.
And so I got a job dubbing voices
in foreign films.
And if you don't know what dubbing is,
and we do it in American
TV and movies too,
if the sound is bad, you
gotta go into a studio
and then re-do the sentence.
Like for instance, let's do it now.
- Okay. Let's do it.
- Okay, so--
- Ooh, I like it.
It's a game. I'm in.
Yeah. (laughter) That's my energy.
- So exciting. Contagious.
- Yeah, sorry.
- So now just say this line.
Say the line, "Melvin, I
have to devein the shrimp."
Just say it.
- Melvin, I have to devein the shrimp.
- Now I heard a sound, so
we have to take that out.
You have to...
- Open my mouth.
- But it's in another language
so I have to find the line to
fit the same kind of mouth flaps,
but I have to put in a line
that's germane to whatever
film I'm trying to...
- So like if I'm going to mouth that...
- Say Melvin...what did you have to say?
- Melvin, I have to devein the shrimp.
- So now don't do any voice now.
Beep, beep, beep.
There's a monster in the living room.
(laughter)
- Listen...
- I wasn't ready for that.
- You're a terrible beeper.
- I wasn't ready for the
(inaudible), I wasn't
ready for that.
- You have to approximate your
character and your whole...
- No.
- That's amazingly hard.
- Let's do it again.
- I can't look at you.
- Don't look at me.
- Melvin, I have to devein this shrimp.
- If I had a nickel for
every time I've heard that.
All right now listen, I'm
going to count down, ready?
- Okay.
- Beep, beep, beep.
There's a monster in the living room.
(laughter and clapping)
See?
So that's it.
(laughter and clapping)
- So randomly enough, I walked
in to watch my daughter.
She's five, and I let her just pick
something on Netflix.
I was doing something.
All of a sudden, I'm like, why
are they speaking Spanish?
She watches things that are from Spanish,
but they'll try to do them in English.
Half the episode is English.
They do that a lot, still.
- Yes. Part of the problem is that
in different languages
there's different cadences,
and different rhythms.
- Yeah, rhythm.
- So that's why if you
watch a lot of old movies,
you'll hear people talking
like this over there
because they try to fit in dialog
into foreign mouth flapping.
- Oh, my God. That's hard.
And hard not to laugh, obviously.
- Hard not to laugh.
You need time.
- I know, I know.
You know what? I should just steer clear.
- Forget it.
- I feel like I should forget it.
- You're doing too much already.